I'm from New York.
And one of the things that I miss about New York...
...was that when you're waiting for a long light...
...at the intersection to cross.
Almost every time, if you get there and you're just not able to cross the street...
...and you decide to wait for the light to turn green,...
...someone will start talking to you...
...or you will start talking to somebody.
It's like this sort of demilitarized zone.
At each intersection and then the light turns red,...
...you just get to talk to people who are around you.
That is cool.
And it's wonderful because the light is gonna turn green,...
...and then that's a very comfortable, natural way to just sort of...
...move back into the stream of your day,...
...and just sort of separate from someone.
Yeah, with little interaction.
You can have a little interaction, you go off...
...and you have a sense of what that person's soul is,...
...you know, sort of and what they're like.
If your car stopped at the light, they'll come up and wash your window.
If you park your car, they'll sometimes break the window.
They'll pull you out, steal your car. Carjacking.